the U.S Secretary of States met senior
Chinese Diplomat Wang Yi in Munich for
the first time since Washington accused
Beijing of sending a spy balloon into
its airspace U.S fighter jets shot down
in the balloon over the Atlantic earlier
this month Anthony blinken says he made
it clear that violations of American
airspace must never happen again Wang is
calling the response hysterical
insisting it was a weather balloon that
blew off course
there was no apology but what I can also
tell you is this was an opportunity to
speak very clearly and very directly
about the fact that China sent a
surveillance balloon over our territory
violating our sovereignty violating
international law and I told him quite
simply that that was unacceptable and
can never happen again we're of course
not the only ones on the receiving end
of these surveillance balloons more than
40 countries have had these balloons fly
over them in recent years and that's
been exposed to the world
Andy Marcus from the center for China
and globalization he says Washington is
engaging in double standards
a weather balloon uh collecting uh
weather information certainly can have
uh military use uh so I think it's very
unclear here um and I think it's also
important to point out that uh certainly
uh the U.S complaining about this
violation of sovereignty uh does sound a
little bit uh hypocritical I mean we go
back decades with the U.S engaging in
this kind of alleged conduct uh all
around the world so I think we really do
should take this with a bit of a grain
of salt and there also is a narrative
battle taking place here and Once Upon a
Time the U.S certainly could credibly
warn China warn any other country around
the world but I think the geopolitical
realities are shifting and how credible
this warning is I think remains to be
seen as we see not only China but other
countries around the world increasingly
able to act with a greater degree of
autonomy free from U.S uh coercion
perhaps we could call it well the final
day of the Munich security conference is
now underway with U.S China relations
and the Ukraine war continuing to
dominate the agenda our diplomatic
editor James base is joining us live now
uh from unique James we're going to
start with a meeting between Anthony
blinken and Wang Yi the the talking as
mine might have expected was did at
least sound pretty tough what's equally
interesting of course is the fact that
the meeting happened at all
yeah absolutely any meeting I think from
both sides perspective is good news but
it seems to have been a pretty tense
exchange of words and it wasn't a very
long meeting and I don't think it's it's
necessarily done what uh some had hoped
which is uh get the relationship back
onto a place where the two could
actually have a more constructive
meeting remember that at the time that
the Spy balloon was shot down over North
American airspace secretary blinking was
just about to land in Beijing the first
meeting involving a secretary of state
going to China for some considerable
time and that meeting although the U.S
say they're still looking for a later
date for it it has not been set that new
date so I think a slight bit of progress
maybe that they met I think in terms of
what's actually been achieved in the
Munich security conference one of the
things I think that's important or we
don't know how important yet does come
from China because China is signaling
that with regards to the war in Ukraine
it's got an idea for some sort of plan
moving forward and China is probably one
of the only countries that has
significant influence on Russia so I
think we're going to need to see in
European diplomats are saying we don't
really get a comment on this or say much
about it until we see the details but I
think it's important to watch those
details on what China apparently is
going to unveil in the coming days yeah
James let's stick with the Ukraine war
we're of course approaching the one-year
anniversary of the war you've been
speaking to some of the most significant
voices at the security conference what
are they saying about the state of the
war
well they say that they fear it's going
to be a long War I think they're all
accepting now that uh President Putin is
unlikely uh to back down any time soon
that they're seeing the strategy that's
being used he's sending more and more
troops into uh eastern Ukraine many of
those troops have been described by
European diplomats as cannon fodder but
they see that for now anyway he fears
that if he doesn't continue the war on
its current course then it may affect
him and his standing uh back in Moscow
there is talk uh not very public talk
from some European diplomats about
negotiations and a time to negotiate for
now they say the timetable needs to be
set by president zielinski now we know
what president zielinski is saying
privately he's saying yes I'm happy to
talk once Russia withdraws and when he
says withdraws he doesn't just mean from
the areas they've taken in the last year
he means from all of Ukraine and that
doesn't seem something that the uh that
the
Russians are likely to do anytime soon
and President Putin's very unlikely I
think to withdraw uh from Crimea so the
message publicly is for as long as it
takes but I think there's a problem with
that going going forward and one of the
big problems is not with the Europeans
it's with the U.S because remember we've
only got a couple of years until the
next U.S election campaign uh Wars
abroad are not particularly popular in
the U.S certainly many Republicans
elected to the House of Representatives
say no more blank checks from UK Ukraine
and we know that certain Republican
candidates we don't know all the
candidates are going to be for president
but we know one of them is President
Trump and we know how he sometimes
completely changes uh the U.S foreign
policy position on issues I think not
many will be surprised here in the
possibility that there was another
president Trump term that he might
change the policy on Ukraine completely
so I think the commitment for as long as
it takes is as long as it takes until
the U.S potentially changes its mind our
diplomatic editor James bays in Munich
James thank you